[ PANTING ]
Narrator:
YEAH, MIKE AND ADAM HAVE
OBVIOUSLY BEEN WORKING TO HARD.
BUT WHY IS DOSH PANTING
LIKE A STEAM TRAIN?
WHEN MAMMALS GET TOO HOT,
THEIR MAIN WAY OF COOLING OFF
IS THROUGH A PROCESS CALLED
EVAPORATIVE COOLING.
AND THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY THE PROCESS
THAT TURNS WATER
FROM A LIQUID TO A VAPOR,
ABSORBING ENERGY WITH IT
AS IT DOES IT.
IN HUMANS, EVAPORATIVE COOLING
TAKES PLACE ON OUR SKIN,
WHERE SWEAT GLANDS PRODUCE SWEAT
WHICH THEN EVAPORATES
TO COOL US DOWN.
BECAUSE HUMANS CAN SWEAT,
THIS EVAPORATIVE COOLING
TAKES PLACE
ALL OVER OUR BODIES.
BUT WITH DOGS,
IT ONLY TAKES PLACE
IN A COUPLE TINY SPOTS
ON THEIR PAWS WHERE
THEY HAVE SWEAT GLANDS.
SO THEY HAVE TO FIND
OTHER MOIST SURFACES
TO EVAPORATE WATER FROM,
WHICH WOULD BE THEIR MOUTH,
THEIR TONGUE,
AND THEIR NASAL PASSAGES.
THOSE LOCATIONS HAVE
A LOT OF BLOOD VESSELS.
SO WHAT HE'S COOLING DOWN
IS THE BLOOD INSIDE
THOSE VESSELS
WHICH CIRCULATES
THROUGHOUT HIS WHOLE BODY,
THUS COOLING HIM OFF.
Narrator:
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILLING OUT,
DOSH HAS IT LICKED, NO SWEAT.